[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
doors I prefer to think of it dear
Johnny Hank it's a comedy podcast where
two brothers answer your questions give
me two Bs advice and for you all the
week's news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon
John yes did you know that you have an
iron deficiency how so I can tell cuz
your shirts are all wrinkly
oh it took me a second I've got it now I
I'm still not laughing but I have
received the joke do you have good news
from the world for me John not only do I
have good news for you Hank I have an
ongoing source of good news I know that
you have a Google home as I do mm-hmm
starting now if you ask Google assistant
hey Google tell me something good Google
will provide you with good news
some piece of good news about how the
world is getting better beekeepers in
East Detroit bringing back the dwindling
bee population Iceland curbing teen
drinking with nightly curfews and
coupons for kids to enroll in
extracurricular activities etc I like
the coupons for extracurricular
activities but come on let the kids go
outside I wonder if you could do it by
singing to it I wonder if you say like
hey Google tell me something good if
it'll still work I mean there's only one
way to find out I unfortunately I'm not
in a room with Google home but I will
just say for people who's who are
listening out loud in a room with Google
hum hey Google tell me something good I
think I actually like my version of
singing that song better than I like
your version you know it's not a
competition not not every singing has to
be rated but if you go to if you go on
my Twitter I will post a poll and people
can say which one they liked better I
was just pointing out that usually I'm
overwhelmingly the the lesser singer and
I think at least that time I was
sells clothes I think you did well right
hmm yeah good job let's answer some
questions for rogue listeners it sounds
like a good plan uh I do love our
opening bits though I had a I had a good
old time this first question is a real
doozy and it comes from Kiki who asks
dear Hank and John my name is Kiki and I
recently broke up with my boyfriend of a
year and a half it was pretty rough and
I ended up telling him that I didn't
love him anymore a couple of days later
Drake's in my feelings came out so my
question is how do you make a wildly
successful pop song less successful so
that your ex-boyfriend doesn't have to
keep listening to Drake singing Kiki do
you love me approximately two million
times a day best wishes Kiki who sadly
does not love you this is awful
okay so full disclosure Hank I am not
familiar with this tune uh would you
like me to perform it for you ideally
not but all excit key do you love me are
you ride in so you never ever leave from
beside me cuz I want you and I need you
good as you can see how Kiki's
ex-boyfriend would be upset by this
being on the radio all the time I can't
believe you haven't heard it it's it's a
huge big hit and people get there in
their car and they could get out of
their car to do a special dance that I
don't even think was Drake's idea I
think that was like an internet thing
there's a special Kiki dance and you
have to be outside of your car walking
with your car cuz I guess you're writing
it's unclear to me but it's a meme Kiki
if I were you I would change your name
and then call your ex-boyfriend and say
update Nicole doesn't love you now yeah
or like find somebody else named Kiki to
just go on just like just like be like
look I'm not gonna date you but I did
want you to know that like I love I love
all children of God including you yeah
that's another thing you could do is
make a best friend who's name is Kiki
and then have them call your
ex-boyfriend and say I love you as a
person but just to be clear not as a
boyfriend I don't like what you did to
Kiki oh gosh there are those moments
this would be horrible
admittedly I found that yeah I was
exiting romantic relationships a lot of
things would have to change in my life
in order for me to go through the
grieving process like I would have to
completely stop listening to the music
that we listen to as a couple and I
would also in many cases like have to
move neighborhoods because I didn't want
to go to the same sushi restaurant
anymore I didn't want to do the things
that I had done but the truth is Kiki
when you first break up with someone
like when you're first in that period of
grief and loss and mourning
you don't need Drake to remind you
because you're always anything the
person anyway yeah it's anything will
remind you of them but but this does you
know it reminds me that there are these
moments in in our lives where we will
feel as if the universe is conspiring
against us as if they're there it was
all a computer simulation in order to
make us feel this feeling because
otherwise this seems impossibly
vanishingly small probability for
something like this to happen but it had
to happen to someone because there are
key keys out there and they do break up
from their boyfriends it's a thing that
was bound to happen I guess and it's
sort of remarkable that we got to hear
from one of them well actually what we
need is a support group for all people
who recently broke up with Kiki's and
just and the knowledge that like for
then it's not just now because it's
gonna be for the rest of this person's
life because this song is a big enough
hit that it's gonna be playing on radio
stations in 30 years if there are still
radio stations which of course there
won't be but whatever and and and they
will still have to be like I hate this
song and people be like why do you hate
this song Kiki do you that and they'd be
like no stop I don't want to talk about
it those kinds of coincidences always
remind me of my friend Amy cross
Rosenthal who was fascinated by
coincidence and who often wrote that she
understood that life was random and that
coincidences were not meaningful
inherently but that you could still make
meaning out of whatever you want to and
I think that's so true and so maybe
Kiki's ex-boyfriend maybe you can
make some kind of positively meaningful
coincidence out of this I don't know
that's my only threat of hope we do have
another question about computer
simulations though Hank oh gosh well I
mean I'm actually not surprised I've
been hearing a lot about computer
simulations lately the question is from
Micah Dear John and Hank I was excited
to find out that mystery socks are
available at the dftba online store and
I immediately went to dftba.com to buy
some and it was a great experience but I
have a question about birds I mean it we
we should probably try to integrate more
of our sponsors in this way the question
do the do the work of the sponsor promo
let's oh man I really enjoyed the new
game from Bananagrams but I have a
question about donkeys I work at a
coffee shop and it gets really boring
and this evening I was standing outside
the back door gazing across a grassy
field when I noticed a bird flying
around but then it stopped moving in the
air but kept flapping its wings it
looked like something had tied a string
to its tail and was holding it back from
moving it was hovering like people do in
those fake skydiving places
it wasn't flapping its wings so hard but
going nowhere and it looked kind of like
a glitch in a video game is this a
metaphor for the constant and ultimately
pointless pursuit of meaning in our
lives or is this proof that we are
living in a simulation I'm not a rock or
a book
I'm just Micah John do you know what
it's so first of all I say you're with
your coffee shop and you like walk out
the back of your coffee shop and there's
just a field with birds this isn't how I
pictured most coffee shops where is this
yeah Micah it might be that your work is
boring because you're working in a
coffee shop in the middle of a field
like you might have located your
business in the wrong location if I want
to write a letter to your manager and
just saying like maybe we should have
put it not in a field
hey the birds the birds don't want
coffee Susan the birds don't want coffee
listen Susan this is a crazy idea but
what if our coffee shop was accessible
by Road
yeah you don't have to drive an ATV to
it that would be great it's a walk for
three miles of corn so there are some
birds of prey small birds of prey that
do this and they will fly looking for
things that might be food and then they
will stop and they can actually flap
their over the thing before they go and
get the thing that the rodent or
whatever it is that looked tasty to them
so that's probably what's going on
kestrels can do this that is probably
what you saw was a Kestrel flying around
looking for a snack and it saw something
that might be a snack and it was hanging
there looking and seeing if it had a
good good line on this little piece of
snack well that's good news so it's not
a glitch in the matrix yeah and we're
definitely not living in a simulation
Micah don't worry about that I started
to not want to make jokes about living
in a simulation anymore because I've
started to see people who are like
legitimately on the conspiracy train
about being in a simulation oh I think
it's perfectly possible that we're
living in a simulation I just don't
think it's an interesting line of
inquiry it's like asking how many angels
you can fit on the head of a pin it
doesn't matter I think that it's oh
here's my here's my hot take on whether
we're living in a simulation I think
that that knowing that I lived in a
simulation would be interesting from a
cosmological perspective of like trying
to understand the nature of the universe
but it would not at all affect affect
the way that I live my life right
because I might as well be living in a
simulation right like the there is no
objective meaning or value I apply all
of that myself then we do that
collectively as a as a species and as
living things on this planet and it but
like external to that no no no no
there's nothing there so it's all on us
anyway whether it's a simulation or
whether it's just a very complicated
weird expanding bubble of space-time
yeah no I feel the exact same way in
general there are so many questions that
the Internet is obsessed with that I
think are really really boring and that
is one of them that's just the internet
job that's just that's how it's always
been people I mean we did our
Kriss philosophy and the the amount of
time we spent talking about how much
time people spent talking about whether
or not God exists
is amazing another question I like I'm a
religious person and I find that
question so profoundly uninteresting and
all of that is a perfectly legitimate
response to a question about birds I
guess is where we're at
John life is ultimately meaningless and
we're all going to die what's our next
question it's not ultimately meaningless
we just make the meaning all right Hank
this next one comes from no I'm gonna do
two in a row Dear John and Hank I'm
sitting across from a sign for a
dentist's office and if I'm translating
the sign correctly I am living abroad it
says they treat teeth of all types are
there other types of teeth ah well I
mean animals they may be the treat
turtle teeth turtles don't have teeth
maybe they treat giraffe teeth turtles
do have teeth turtles have teeth yes
hold on turtles have teeth right Google
[Music]
know they have beaks do turtles have
teeth hold on hold on that that's a neat
question I have raised turtles and I've
never thought about that really any
question I've never looked at one I've
raised 4642 turtles but I've never seen
the inside of a mouth I just don't
actually care to look at them I'm a big
fan of turtles but I don't like the way
they look so I just sort of like to be
near them John turtles don't have teeth
I'm not giving up you go on with your
answer and I'm going to find a turtle
with teeth well John I will tell you
that the esophagus of a leatherback sea
turtle is lined with papal I that are
sharp and keratinized so they they are
like teeth but they don't go where teeth
go there on the throat and in the cheeks
and if you see a picture of it you will
make this noise
so there you go
dentist in the country you're visiting
treats to turtle teeth like structures
on the turtle tongue yeah you know
keratinized papillae oh man I wish I
hadn't googled that guys no matter what
you do never Google turtle tongue teeth
Oh God oh what's the noise you make oh
gee oh god
I don't like it I don't like it at all
oh god that felt do you know that
leatherback sea turtles can eat 85% of
their weight and jellyfish every day so
how many jellyfish have died get swamped
by those things not enough John is now a
fan of the the carotenoids papillae cuz
now he knows that they they remove
jellyfish from the oceans because you
hate jellyfish I'm packing geez I'm back
on team turtle man jellyfish and turtles
it's the circle of life this next
question comes from Carolyn who asks
dear Hank and John I live with my
boyfriend and I'm often the one who does
the laundry in the house as a result I
tend to find a lot of loose pocket
change which I add to my change jar I
believe this is standard laundry
practice that the person who does the
laundry gets the loose change but I
still feel like I'm siphoning off yes
siphoning money off your boyfriend yes
you're doing that no he's very absent
mindedly no change in his pockets what
and also lots of tissues Hank we're
about to have our biggest fight ever
no you kid this is just theft no it is
not theft it is payment for services
rendered I just started a load of
laundry which contained two dollars and
two tissues is this fair exchange and
what a monetary quantity do I need to
return that but what no this is stealing
does he know is there an agreement in
place have you signed a contract Hank if
you're doing laundry anything that is
left in the pockets of the laundry is
yours that's one of the like great
organizing principles of the universe
like if you don't want to lose your
pocket change or by the way a $100 bill
or $47,000 in cash or whatever is in
your pockets then empty out your flippin
pockets before you put it in the dirty
laundry basket like anything you put in
the dirty laundry basket the person who
does that laundry gets to keep hard stop
nope yes
no they sell like there's this idea that
this is some kind of established
contract that you seem to think
everybody knows about but I clearly do
not know about it so not everyone knows
about it my only conclusion is that
you've literally never been to a
laundromat what do you mean I've never
been to a lot like who does your laundry
at the laundromat you do your own
laundry
nobody's touching my pockets in the many
years when I lived with roommates if I
did their laundry or they did mine
whatever was in the pockets was 100%
fair your roommates laundry because like
crap would be lying on the floor and one
person would do it or the other person
would do it like even when but when
Katherine and I were dating I didn't
take the money when I did her laundry
that was her money no no it's it's your
money if you pull it out of your pockets
before putting it in the before putting
it in the laundry it is the moment it
hits the laundry pile and you don't do
the laundry you lose all rights to that
money I mean I I hear I hear that this
is a rule that you can set up in your
home but it is not a rule that is
implicit in society but I will say John
that I did do this to you when I did
your laundry when we lived together and
I felt bad about it every time it was
theft and I just did it alright I
completely absolved you of any guilt
that you feel of her stealing 40 cents
for me when you were cleaning my pants
however since we brought it up I do not
absolve you for selling my flipping
baseball card collection on eBay without
consulting me uh I mean that was worse
than the pants thing yeah it was
considerably worse you made like 800
dollars off of my baseball cards that
were a huge part of my childhood you
left them at the house and you just left
them there I didn't take them to my dorm
room when I went to college that's not
the same thing as no longer wanting to
own my Carl Yastrzemski rookie card it's
sort of amazing that that like of the
things I've done I've
actually gotten not as much flak for
that as I should have
thank you few been very kind about that
over the years I like I have fee I have
friends I've lost over much less yeah
just to be clear it's not even that it
was that bad of a thing to do it's just
that it was so weird I don't know to me
it speaks to your absolute obsession
with turning things into money but yeah
yeah yeah if you want to um that's like
a diva how am I gonna monetize my
boredom cuz honestly if you want to
psychoanalyze me it's that I was bored
and I was like how do I do something
that will make my time seem worthwhile
yeah well as like a as like a 15 year
olds why don't I sell my brothers 4,000
very carefully organized baseball cards
while he's working at outtakes
restaurant in Homewood Alabama he's
making this you're making this sound
making this sound worse than it was I
don't know how many baseball cards there
were I don't remember any of this I
plead the fifth the statute of
limitations are is out on this one I'm
done no more oh well I will not submit
to further questions I turned down the
subpoena
okay this decks all right okay we are
well and truly off the rails this next
question comes from Emmy who writes Dear
John and Hank I recently deleted Twitter
congratulations Emmy due to reasons
concerning my mental health yes no
that's implied in the sentence I
recently deleted Twitter but there are
times when I miss it Oh Emmy we all miss
things that are bad for us but we
stopped them anyway how do you think I
feel about smoking cigarettes anyway I
was wondering if you could fill me in on
everything I'm missing on Twitter also
what's lin-manuel Miranda up to these
days Oscars and Emmy a very good name
specific sign-off lin-manuel miranda is
wonderful he's very sweet he doesn't he
doesn't seem to interact that much with
Twitter except to say nice things on it
for the most part which is probably the
right way to do it what else are you
missing boy boy I don't even know where
to start there people are confused and
frustrated yeah I mean Emmy I would I'd
stay off I'm sorry I was trying to
answer your question Emmy but it
required me to get on
Twitter and now I've been sucked into
the vortex I'm having a little trouble
paying attention yeah
literate literally like you asked the
question about Twitter and John and I
are both like what huh what is it I hate
like why'd you say John I didn't hear
you I hate the way Twitter makes me feel
and I hate the way it makes me act and I
hate the way it makes me interact which
is actually come to think of it not
dissimilar to how I felt about smoking
cigarettes for the last eight years that
I smoked cigarettes
there is a here's here's a little update
John from Hank did not hear anything I
just said because it's so so very
correct because I was looking at the
Twitter feed for delete this which
follows three people yeah delete this
follows Suzy dent the linguist yep and
Hank green the author of an absolutely
remarkable thing that comes out
September 25th and is available for
pre-order now and we and we're eight
dogs right so though that that Twitter
feed honestly that's probably about what
I'm looking for I would argue that you
could take Hank off of it might be a
good choice honestly I find a lot of
Hanks tweets to be engaged in unhealthy
ways with the feed honestly if you go
and look at my feed verses here for you
recently I think maybe in the last 24
hours but I just deleted Twitter off my
phone while we were having this
conversation because Emmys question made
me realize that I think I'm done like I
needed to quit smoking and there were a
lot of people who were like hey you know
what you need to do quit smoking and I'd
be like ya know I mean I probably should
it's I recognize it's not great for me
but that's it I'm quitting smoking I
need to quit smoking Hank this is
ridiculous like why can't I be an adult
about this
I quit smoking I can quit this well ask
you know John I have a podcast called
delete this with my wife where I talk
about my my connection with social media
and through thinking about that the
thing that I can't leave behind is this
feeling that this is how this is how the
conversation is being had right now and
if people like I'll remove themselves
from it and I'm not saying like don't
treat it more in a more healthy way
don't like couldn't like don't like
change the way you
think about it both in terms of like
your use of it and in terms of of how
you connect with people through it but I
feel like if you just if we leave the
conversation up to everyone who is not
thinking constructively then then like
dude what do we lose like am i I might
be wrong but it feels like this is where
the this is where the conversation is
being had
and so like we need to be where the
conversation is I think you're wrong
over 95% of people do not post a tweet
on any given day 85% of Americans do not
look at Twitter on any given day I don't
think the conversation is happening on
Twitter I think our conversation is
happening on Twitter I think Twitter is
very good at making us feel like a big
important central conversation is
happening on Twitter but I just don't
think that Twitter is essential to my
survival now I will get on it in
September to tell everybody to buy your
book and I will continue to use it for
self promo but I don't know something
about Emmys question really reinforced
to me that it isn't making my life
better and it isn't and it it is harming
my life and I get something in exchange
for that like I understand what she
means about like there are times when I
miss it
but I don't get enough in exchange for
it for what it's costing me yeah I think
that's a decision that has to be made
individually but like ma I do feel like
and and of course that there's a
tremendous amount of like selection bias
here like of course I feel like this is
where I think the conversation is having
because it's where I'm having a
conversation but like I do feel like
they're you know like I need to be aware
of how people are communicating right
now and and also need to be ideally in
some way a positive part of that
communication so so for me it's more
like how do I treat this in a more
healthy way than how do I not use it
it's it's it's less cigarettes and more
coffee you know yeah I'm not sure that
for me there's any any safe dosage also
I need coffee like it's not to be a
not like food is not a good comp con job
just to be clear coffee is not food yeah
but I need it every day so it's kind of
like food no you don't need coffee I do
maybe maybe one doesn't do you want
another question yeah this one is from
Bowl recipient dear Hank John my
mother-in-law's in their bowl recipient
mother-in-law's a fan of giving gifts
that she would like without considering
whether the person receiving it would
like it objects she has given me and
various people include giant glass orbs
giant commemorative coins and the gift I
received recently an oddly shaped
expensive decorative Bowl parentheses
not giant I don't know what to do with
this bowl I feel like putting things in
it would be inappropriate due to a
three-dimensional nature it takes up a
lot of space when it's displayed as a
bowl space I don't really have I could
get a mount for the bowl but I worry
that I would somehow display it
incorrectly I do not like this bowl I
cannot get rid of this bowl please help
me figure out what to do sincerely bowl
recipient I like that they didn't want
us to use their name because yeah our
mother in law probably listens to the
pod and would is probably right now like
well I mean it's a good thing that my
daughter in law loves bowls she doesn't
have any problems with the bowl I've
given her right this must be a real
problem for other people if you a bowl
recipient here's what you gotta do you
gotta say thank you so much for this
bowl I love it and get ready for the
rest of your life collecting bowls no no
no Wyatt we've disagreed for the most
we've ever disagreed on the podcast I
don't know what's in the I don't know
what's in the water today but I
completely agree that you have to accept
the bowl and say that you love it you
don't have to be so enthusiastic that
your mother and well now thinks that
you're a huge bowl fan and starts buying
you a bowl on on her various travel
I think though this is the key ball
recipient when your mother-in-law is
visiting or is about to visit you put
out the bowl maybe you put a couple
pairs in there I don't know how you
handle it but you put the bowl out
somewhere and then when your
mother-in-law isn't visiting you put the
bowl away but where's away doesn't find
there's a ton a place to put this bowl
oh you have to have well no you got
maybe you have to get a piece of
furniture and on the very inside of it
you just have labelled crap from my
mother-in-law and it's great to have all
of that stuff together by the way my
mother-in-law is wonderful and gives
great gifts just for the record that's
the truth I'm saying the truth
but I am also saying that just be 100
percent clear because she does listen to
the podcast I love you Connie and thank
you for all of your wonderful gifts over
the years moving on you just have a
little area of your house that's like
stuff from for when my mother-in-law
visits and then right before your
mother-in-law comes you grab everything
out of that little closet and you put it
around your house in various places and
you just do that for the rest of your
life because that is the best solution
yeah you go to well you got to go to the
Container Store and get something that's
gonna fit under your bed or something it
sounds like maybe you live in a pretty
small place and you don't want to like
be harboring bowls for no reason but you
have to Harbor bowls and it's not no
reason it is a reason it's just not that
you love this bowl it's a separate
reason from your your feelings about the
bowl right no it's about you loving your
family and dealing with the minor
inconveniences that accompany love I
will say Bowl recipient that one
strategy you might try is sitting down
with your mother-in-law and saying hey
would you like to watch an episode of
The Simpsons and show her the episode of
The Simpsons where Homer gives Marge a
birthday present that is a bowling ball
drilled to his fingers I mean but that's
not that's not this because the the
mother-in-law isn't giving you a gift
for her she's giving you a gift that she
would like which is not not it's a
failure of empathy
it is not a explicit
of your value to her value but yeah I
think that a lot of people are like oh
man I love so much the beautiful bowls
that I have in my house but it's also a
little bit of a statement on like
wouldn't you like to make your place
look nicer here's a bowl put some fake
fruit in it yeah so it's a smidge
passive-aggressive for sure but again
these are the little prices that you pay
in order to live in community with other
people so I think it's worth it
Bal recipient but if you want to make a
stink about it it's up to you I think
that one thing that's weird about
decorative bowls is that you can't put
that many things in them but there are
some things you can put in them I feel
like if you put them in the middle of a
table and you put fruit in them then
they can be useful because you do need
to put fruit somewhere and speaking of
fruit I have another question for you
Judd a great transition hang-its from
jasmine who who asks dear Hank and John
I'm in the kitchen and I have decided to
make cupcakes this is a great decision
it's wonderful I don't normally cook
frankly I'm quite terrible when it comes
to anything remotely related to a
kitchen but today I have decided to try
I have all the right ingredients to make
cupcakes the Box mix ready to go but I'm
out of eggs
Jamin hold on you don't have all the
ingredients jasmine there's only two
ingredients the Box mix and eggs maybe
some milk
you have your basic at least 33% of the
ingredients Jasmine you made it sound
like you're almost all the way there but
though you're at most two-thirds of the
way there I'm a bit disappointed and I
wanted to make these cupcakes for my
friends and it got me wondering what can
I use instead of eggs and why does a
cake even need eggs bunch of reasons
first gosh eggs are very important to
baking but you can use other things so
yes Sara and I have actually
experimented with this what most people
use that I've seen is like a weird mix
of water and baking powder and oil but
if you don't have eggs I'm kind of
suspicious as to whether you have baking
powder another thing that people use is
applesauce yeah I think
a quarter cup of applesauce if that is
gonna be as good but it adds some of the
add some of the the protein the problem
is your chocolate cupcakes are a Polly
my favorite thing actually we made
chocolate cupcakes once using bananas
instead of eggs and that was quite good
because a chocolate banana combo is
tasty but it will make your cupcakes
taste like bananas right that will that
is the thing that happens so what I
Jasmine a thing that I just want to say
to you generally is that like you're
asking too many questions we don't need
to know why cakes need eggs I bet
there's a reason I bet egg you could
google it and find it out but look you
and me Jasmine we're not we're not
experts we're not bakers that's why
Betty Crocker is doing the work for us
we are gonna have to rely on the
centuries and millennia of knowledge
that that human Baker's have gathered so
that we don't have to think thoughts
like why do cakes need eggs
we could just do what we're told and
then make something delicious Hank green
relating every single question to his
core belief that people need to believe
in expertise again make expertise
relevant again the Hank green campaign
model like what what do we have against
Betty Crocker's expertise she's been
doing this for longer than hoop like a
human can be alive the truth I don't
know I was about to google it honestly
great great question
1921 unfortunately so Betty Crocker
could still be alive if Betty Crocker
was a person it would be very difficult
I did not know that Betty Crocker was a
fictional character until just now she
was created by a guy named Bruce Barton
Wow in honor of it was also a member of
the United States House of
Representatives oh well good for you I
mean what-what had more lasting impact
I would say Congress but that one
interesting question but I'd probably
lean toward the United States Congress
in terms of institutions that's just
about the Betty Crocker Wikipedia page
now and it says Betty Crocker also
appears as an antagonist in the popular
web comic Homestuck of course Holmes
Doug people have have their media in
Wikipedia wherever it is possible to get
it in yeah Wikipedia is actually itself
essentially an extension of Homestuck
it's like 10% of Wikipedia is Homestuck
references it's just that's what they've
been doing with their time now which is
great I think it's great I should I
should add that Betty Crocker was
popularized by someone else named
Marjorie
husted who also was the voice of Betty
Crocker in addition to writing the radio
scripts so there you go that's my entire
history of Betty Crocker just inserted
into a podcast if you liked that you'll
love my podcast the anthropocene
reviewed in which I will be reviewing
Betty Crocker very shortly [ __ ] our our
patron only podcast this week in Ryan's
which may have may also have something
to do with Betty Crocker we'll see what
happens I think we have to try to
finally get through an actual sandra by
episode that's an inside joke that only
Hank and me and the 14 people who listen
to this weekend Ryan it's dangerous
ground which reminds me that this
podcast is brought to you by John's
podcast the Anthropocene reviewed
there's a podcast that is about what is
it about Chuck thanks never listened
today's podcast is also brought to you
by turtles tongue teeth turtles tongue
teeth it's a thing it's a thing podcast
is also brought to you by carl
yastrzemski when he was a rookie he had
a baseball card and I sent it to a
stranger you you literally don't know
Carl Yastrzemski 'he's name i'm looking
at the way that you spelled you Stremme
ski on the podcast notes and i'm duly
horrified finally today's podcast is
brought to you by decorative
balls decorative bowls coming soon to
your home via your mother-in-law the
anthropocene reviewed is a podcast where
I reviewed different facets of the human
centered planet on a five-star scale you
should listen to it it's available
wherever you get your podcast unless you
get your podcasts on Spotify we also
have a project for awesome message from
Carla Potter where Solomon Carla thank
you for donating the project for awesome
to get us to read this to you and to
everyone else who listens to the pod hi
my name is Carla I'm a 26 year old
nerdfighter currently residing in
Flushing New York and working in the
nonprofit sector you both inspire me
because you wear your values and
nerdiness like other people wear
designer clothing
God knows Hank doesn't wear designer
clothing publicly and with pride I want
you all to know that I exist
so please affirm I John Green am
consciously aware of the existence of
Carla pad or Salomon indeed I am Carla
thank you for donating to the project
for awesome and for all your great work
either you're part of the simulation or
we are who knows okay I have a really
big question for you this might be the
best question we've ever received on our
podcast Dear John and Hank you guys have
talked about how hard it is to change
someone else's mind but how do you
change your own mind I know what love is
Jenni hmm I mean do you want to yeah
there are times when you have to change
your mind right like there are times
when you're wrong and so the question I
think is how does the process of you
changing your mind work mm-hmm
right and I think that like the the an
important part of that is like it
doesn't happen on its own
you like you don't just get exposed to
new ideas and then and then your mind
like you actually have to be like okay
let me examine my thought structures let
me examine my beliefs let me examine my
values and let me examine like the
reality as it is being portrayed to me
by the simulation and and people on
Twitter and like because because you you
won't change your mind if you don't if
you aren't open to the idea of having
your mind changed
because I I don't think that like I
think that every time it's happened for
me it's it's it's been a combination of
an involuntary like this is a thing that
I'm M hat is happening and I kind of
don't even want to recognize that it's
happening because I will like my former
self that's still inside of me will feel
mad about it or I will feel as if I'm
betraying that former self and and so
like it's almost something that I don't
want to look right into the face of for
me I have to begin with reminding myself
that I am often wrong that I have been
wrong many times in the past that many
beliefs that I held and cherished
eventually proved to be incorrect that
information that was the most up-to-date
information at the time was later
replaced by information that changed the
understanding we have of the world and
so on so I know that I might be wrong
Hank I completely agree with you that if
you don't start from the perspective of
I might be wrong then you will never
discover that you are but you're wrong
all the time we're all wrong all the
time right like we're we're awash in
misinformation and incomplete
information and so if you just remind
yourself of that it's a lot easier to
change your mind it's also a lot less
humiliating when you have to change your
mind mm-hmm like it it's less
embarrassing it doesn't feel like
something that's core to you has been
ripped apart because to me what's
actually core to me is the understanding
that I'm doing the best I can with the
information that I have but that
information is perpetually inadequate
and maybe that's like another good way
to take this a level deeper to say like
don't base your identity on the
individual beliefs that you have the
individual like this is right this is
wrong I think that like this is sort of
my like perspective on this particular
political debate base your identity on
your values like what do I believe is
the way that humans should live inside
the world what do I think are the things
we should be working for us as
individuals as a country as a species
kind of thing you
Hank I agree this next question comes
from Albert who writes dear John and
Hank over the past few months I've been
working at the fast food chain del Taco
as a grill employee protocol is that
whenever I pull the fries out I shout
hot fries and my co-workers respond
Thank You hot fries this is also the
case for things that I supplied to the
taco bar never wants him i or any other
grill worker referred to by name despite
being on really good relations with
everyone else this raises a few
questions to me many of which are
unsettling is this some form of subtle
corporate dehumanization to rename me
not Albert but hot fries are we all just
perceived by the products that we
produce and not ourselves hey hey hey
Albert that's a high quality name
specific sign-off Albert it is it is but
but I mean why even call yourself Albert
at this point that's right that's right
hot fries thanks for your question hot
fries
I mean the other the other problem that
this has created is the number of people
in the world who now have hot fries as
their nickname has gone up exponentially
since this policy I mean how great of a
nickname is that though I mean
everything us would not want to be known
as hot fries
it's yeah unlike Jasmin who will just
have to call eggless cupcakes way worse
of a nickname yeah I mean imagine like
walking up to a friend and your friend
is like hey hot fries and you're like
hey what's up and then they say hey hot
fries I'd like you to meet my friend Joe
Joe this is my buddy hot fries Joe's
gonna be like I don't know who the hell
that guy is but I want to be friends
with him who doesn't want to be friends
with hot fries like I won't have a best
friend named hot fries so badly uh I
mean there isn't much that I like more
honestly than hot fries yeah here's the
thing Albert I mean hot fries here's the
thing Albert yes every corporation wants
nothing more from you than to extract
more value from your labor than your
labor costs the corporation that noted I
would lean into the hot fries thing the
question is John I want it like when
they say
thank you hot fries do they say thank
you hot fries like they're saying thank
you to Albert and then they are
responding so that everyone knows that
hot fries are the thing that is
happening or are they saying thank you
hot fries as if they are referring to
you as your commodity right which I
would argue the second one is much
better because then your name is hot
fries right but with but in that case
John what would my name be Thank You CEO
of fifth-rate companies John that's not
yeah you I mean you're the CEO of 11
companies that employ a grand total of
22 people del Taco has four hundred
seventy million employees and just I
mean here are more people working for
Del Taco right now as we speak then
there are people living in Europe the
size of that's not true for just to be
very clear not even close
I wasn't planning on calling you out but
there it is I couldn't couldn't handle
it but the size of your company is not
your self-worth John right nor is being
hot fries I guess we should all hope
that you do start calling each other by
your names at some point you don't have
to do it during the during the customary
thank you hot fries moment but at other
moments when you're just talking amongst
yourself and like you do a favor for
somebody or you pick up a shift or you
know go grab the mop bucket from the
back for somebody else they'll say thank
you Albert or and you'll also refer to
them by their name and not their
commodity but in the moment when the hot
fries are have arrived everybody says
thank you hot fries I personally would
like to transition to a world where at
work you only refer to everyone else by
their job like thank you assistant
editor Thank You editorial director no I
don't like it when they were addressing
me they could be like thank you guy who
used to be the CEO but then got demoted
and no longer has a title Thank You
person we don't know what to put on the
business card for
thank you guy who didn't fit into the
org chart because not a great employee
yeah you're adding value it's kind of
you to say I'm happy I'm happy to
commoditize you John I appreciate that I
do report to Hank these days and I have
to say he's a terrible boss
well thanks I'm just kidding you're
great boss what I was looking at Twitter
[Laughter]
all right Hank this question comes from
Lauren who writes Dear John and Hank I'm
starting my senior year of high school
and my schedule this year includes a
student worker position in the art wing
I'm very excited and I know the majority
of this job is going to be cleaning
various things and sorting art supplies
but a large part is also going to
involve filing paperwork after dealing
with college applications I found that I
have a very low tolerance for paperwork
Boren I've got good news and bad news
can I guess which is the good news and
which is the bad news yeah is the bad
news that you you're gonna have to do a
bunch of paperwork not just now but
forever that is the bad news is the good
news that there are podcasts because
like most of people had to do this
before podcasts that's very true
that's very no the good news was gonna
be that on the other side of boredom
lies some kind of transcendent wonder
but why go there when you can just
listen to podcasts agreed all right it's
time for the news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon what's the news from Mars this
week John the update from opportunity is
that there are no updates yet it's
starting to get some sunlight but it may
be the batteries are still recharging
but maybe they aren't and we won't know
for a while but curiosity doesn't have
this problem because it isn't solar
powered it is powered by the heat from
radiation from radioactive materials so
it's all good chugging around and it
recently found a thing that it was that
it was not confused by because it is a
robot that does not have emotions but
NASA scientists were confused by and
there was this little piece
flake in like a little flake of white
stuff on the ground and that's the
scientists were like uh that's kind of
terrifying is that a piece of the rover
that has fallen off is in a piece of an
alien spaceship maybe who knows what it
is and so they had to take a look at
this what they called the Pettigrove
Point foreign object debris I don't know
if you have heard of a THAAD John FOD
foreign object debris but it is
generally a you know something that
shouldn't be there in engineering speak
and so they had this little odd and
didn't know what it was and and looked
at it for a long time
and worked on her for a long time and do
you know what they found out John what
it's a rock it's just a weird rock it's
like a real weird Rock okay so it's part
of Mars
it's a Mars rock it's just a piece of
Mars okay so that's so on Mars we found
a piece of Mars that's exciting but it's
a real weird-looking piece of Mars like
you go look at this in here I just know
a that's a rock yeah but Yetzirah how
could this possibly be a part of Mars
this thing that we found on the surface
of Mars it's crazy
[Laughter]
we wonder if you want to find a reason
to to feel like a Mars rover wasn't
worth the price it's how much time we
just spent being like what is this thing
before we're like oh it's it's Mars but
it's still interesting because it's a
part of Mars that we would not have seen
unless we were able to see it up very
very close and it is a weird little rock
flake it's very it's very light-colored
and it's very thin and long and so it
looks like a coconut like a piece of
shaved coconut is what I'd say the kind
of shaved coconut you put on your really
terrible brownies that didn't have eggs
in them well the news from AFC Wimbledon
is not great
Wimbledon of course have started the
season with two nil nil draws and one
one nil victory things were looking in
short pretty good and then we played
Walsall at home and we lost three
on our first loss of the season it's not
going to be an undefeated season for
Wimbledon yeah so but but what John yes
you scored a goal and like scored a goal
that I feel like matters of lie I don't
know if it actually does but there was
that very long stretch last season where
you just didn't do that yeah so if as
long as you're still scoring goals I
feel good wait listen we are in 11th
place and if we're in 11th place at the
end of the season I will be very happy
so yeah scored some goals well one goal
and I have to say I watched the whole
game now that the AFC Wimbledon app is
so good the video coverage is really
expensive but it is also very good and
you can listen to the the W do n radio
coverage at the same time and it's a
really high quality experience now I
really enjoy watching the games and even
though we lost 3-1 including the worst
own goal I have ever seen in
professional football ever
God will Nightingale god bless him
wonderful kid great player just passed
passed the ball directly into the net as
as cool as you like even though we lost
3-1 I have to say we played well we
don't appear to have a great quality
finisher at the moment like we we are
struggling to score goals but the
passing is really fluid like I even
though we lost 3-1 I thought that
Wimbledon looked better than they did at
almost any point last season it was
really creative flowing football and it
showed me that you know Wimbledon can
play multiple styles which i think is
good news so I don't know even though we
lost I still feel kind of hopeful about
it and again there are worse places to
be than 11th place for instance Oxford
United have played four games and have
zero points Oh
well let's let's do our best to not have
oh I'm just I'm watching the own gold
John oh boy oh yeah it's nice not a good
look yeah I wa I watched it and I was
like what is he Oh Oh God you just say
you just hope that somebody like doesn't
lose confidence you didn't lose to one
yeah I guess that's a good point
oh man all right Hank thank you for
potting with me thanks everybody for
listening we are off to make this
weekend Ryan's our patron only podcast
over at patreon.com slash dear Hank and
John this podcast is edited by Nicholas
Jenkins it's produced by rosianna halse
rojas and sheridan Gibson our head of
community and communications is Victoria
bon giorno the music that you hear right
now and at the beginning of the podcast
is by the great gunnarolla and as they
say in our hometown don't forget to be
awesome
[Music]